Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen vor dem Salon.
Nein, wir sitzen eigentlich im Dachgeschoss, aber...
Ja, jetzt mach doch nicht die ganze Illusion kaputt.
Die Illusion, die virtuelle Realität. Auf der anderen Seite der Kabel.
Nee, es sind ja keine Kabel mehr. Man hört uns ja heute mit kabellosen Kopfhörern.
Ja.
Wir sind trotzdem ganz nah dran.
Und die Illusion reicht vielleicht auch schon. Stimmt.
Ist es alles nur noch Illusion? Also, ich sag mal so, wir haben heute ein Buch.
Das mich sehr begeistert hat, weil es zum einen gut geschrieben,
ich finde es manchmal ein bisschen komisch übersetzt.
Bei manchen Sätzen hätte ich gesagt, nee, da muss man aufpassen,
dass nicht mehrere Sätze mit demselben Wort enden, nur weil es,
also es klingt für mich wie GPT übersetzt.
Ich hatte den Verdacht auch, wenn etwas randständig ist und dann gleich danach,
aber das ist nur am Rande und dann kommt nochmal der Rand vor und dann denke
ich mir, kann das im Original so sein? Ich denke eher nicht.
Ich habe aber nochmal nachgeguckt, es steht vorne ein Übersetzer drin.
Aber wer weiß, welche Techniken der benutzt hat.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Zuhilfenahme von KI inzwischen eine große
Rolle auch beim Übersetzen spielt und dann geht da nochmal ein Mensch drüber. Wir wissen es nicht.
Ich habe festgestellt, wenn ich ein DeepL-Konto habe, könnte ich mir das ganze
Buch mit einem Klick übersetzen lassen. Ja.
So, wenn ich einen Duden-Account habe für automatische Rechtschreibkorrektur,
zum Beispiel in Word, ist es limitiert auf, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten zu buchen,
20.000 oder 40.000 Zeichen im Monat.
So, wenn ich ein Buchautor bin, reicht mir das gar nicht. Ich frage mich,
was der Duden Verlag da oder Cornelsen oder wie die heißen.
Irgendwas stimmt da im Gefüge nicht, im Gesamtgefüge. Also wir haben auf der
einen Seite so Bücher, die uns erklären, die ganze Welt wird revolutioniert,
und dann kommt der Duden Verlag und sagt, Rechtschreibung ist schon wichtig,
aber limitiert auf 40.000 Zeichen pro Monat.
Also irgendwie sehr schräg. Keine Ahnung, was sie da für eine Kundenvorstellung haben.
Ja, ich habe auch diesen Deep Pro Account und das ist wunderbar und habe das
auch schon mehrmals genutzt, also dass ich irgendein spanisches Buch,
dann 400 Seiten PDF da reinlege und innerhalb von einer halben Minute ist es
dann komplett so übersetzt, dass man es lesen kann.
Also ich würde so nicht Literatur mir übersetzen lassen, aber gerade solche
schnell geschriebenen Sachbücher oder so, die kann man schon auch so rezipieren.
Ist mega. Also abgesehen von mündlicher Sprache ist die schriftliche, finde ich, jetzt...
Die Welt steht uns offen. Wenn man überlegt, wie das Internet losging,
irgendwelche Leute haben mit Internetforen und so weiter, da könnte man jetzt
sagen, ja, das ist jetzt alles ohne Sprachbarriere.
Ja, interessanterweise ist aber ja das Internet global gesehen wahnsinnig englisch dominiert.
Also das ist so unglaublich, wenn man sich mal die Zahlen ansieht,
wie viel Prozent zum Beispiel dort andere Weltsprachen ausmachen. Es ist unglaublich.
Unser Internet.
Noch nicht mit Texten aus Indien oder so getestet.
Also das mandarinische Internet mag dann kleiner sein, aber das englische ist
dort eventuell, oder das spanische oder das portugiesische genauso ausgeblendet
wie bei uns das mandarinische.
Fällt mir immer wieder auf, wenn man dann doch mal auf so einer Seite von irgendeinem
japanischen Hersteller ist und dann gibt es nur das englische im Angebot und
aber auch nur so automatisiert übersetzt, also sehr nachrangig,
dann sieht man, okay, es gibt da noch so ein anderes Internet.
Bevor wir aber auf das alles zu sprechen kommen, Korrekturen.
Das Warschauer Dreieck heißt natürlich Weimarer Dreieck.
Kleiner Fehler an der Stelle, aber nur begrifflich. Alles andere wie gesagt.
Feiglandkrieg. Ich habe nur so einen ganz kleinen Halbsatz gemacht.
Und die Argentinien war damals eine Militärdiktatur und durch den Falklandkrieg
zog dann auch ein bisschen mehr Demokratie wieder ein. Nein, keine Ahnung.
Also ich habe mehrere Mails bekommen, die dann auch so Tenor-mäßig,
ich weiß gar nicht, warum in Deutschland der Falklandkrieg immer so und so beachtet wird.
Ich beachte den gar nicht. Ich hatte nur noch im Hinterkopf so ein Gespräch
bei der Daily Show, wo ein aggressiver, Demokratien führen keine Kriege miteinander
und dann wurde irgendwie der Falklandkrieg da so eingeworfen.
Also hatte ich so im Hinterkopf, ah ja, Falklandkrieg steht also gegen diese
Theorie, dass Demokratien keine Kriege direkt miteinander führen,
aber dann kommt er einfach nicht in diese Liste rein und ansonsten habe ich
mir da nicht viel bei gedacht.
Ich habe nochmal kurz nachgelesen und festgestellt, okay, ich hatte keine Ahnung
davon, was damals im Falklandkrieg verhandelt und erkriegt wurde,
außer dass Maggie Thatcher da irgendwie die Hände im Spiel hatte.
Ja und damals, wenn man sich das ansieht, wie dort dieser Krieg rezipiert wurde
in den deutschen Medien, dann ist es natürlich sehr ähnlich mit dem, was heute passiert.
Also es gibt schon so eine unisono Entwicklung sehr schnell.
Und da sind wir ja schon fast bei unserem Thema. Ich habe mir MyTee noch einmal
angesehen, denn du hast das vielleicht mitbekommen.
Noch mal im Sinne von, eigentlich hast du für dein Leben schon abgeschlossen mit
MyTea,
aber….
Freunde der Sonne, hiermit habt ihr jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Hättet ihr mich heute erwartet, hättet ihr Kuchen gemacht oder wenigstens Tee.
Und Tee könnt ihr euch auf jeden Fall machen. Also holt euch einen Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich, wir steigen durch.
Aber das hier ist kein MyLab-Video.
Die Zusammenarbeit mit Funk ist seit dem letzten Video beendet.
Funk hat dieses Video weder bezahlt, noch war Funk inhaltlich involviert.
Ich spreche in diesem Video für mich. Und es geht ausnahmsweise auch nicht um
Wissenschaft, sondern um Politik. So wie es ist, geht es nicht weiter und ich
schaue mir das nicht mehr länger einfach nur an.
Oh mein Gott, was hat sie vor?
Sie will in die Politik. Und wir hören schon am Tonfall, ah ja,
das ist so ganz alarmierend und ich muss jetzt zu euch sprechen.
Das war auch immer ihre Art, wie sie Videos begonnen hat.
Jetzt geht sie also in die Politik. Das wurde dann breit medial rezipiert.
Was wird sie wohl vorhaben?
Geht sie in eine Partei? Gründet sie eine neue?
Macht sie das auf kommunaler Ebene oder geht es doch noch ins Europaparlament?
Moment, nun, es stellt sich heraus, das war ein Prank, denn so sind ja Pranks
bei YouTube angelegt, man sagt so, ich muss mal mit euch reden,
ich glaube, es geht so mit dem Kanal nicht weiter und dann sagt man ja,
ich mache jetzt mal eine Woche Pause und bin dann wieder da.
Ja, so diese Art der Pranks kennen wir und hier jetzt also der Prank,
ich gehe in die Politik, um was zu tun und sie hat dann in diesem Video gesagt,
was ihr alles an der Politik nicht gefällt, die ist nicht vernunftausgerichtet
und nicht listen to the science und die da oben vergessen uns und ich glaube,
ich kann es besser machen, all das.
Ich finde ja noch wichtiger als Prank ist so diese Verbiefung des Internets,
wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, jeder gestaltet sein Content
nur noch mit wem er irgendwie im Streit ist und so.
Ja, und dann kommt der Parabelritter und kann das nochmal alles,
der jetzt auch bei Funk ist, neuerdings.
Also wenn man sich lange genug… Ich glaube.
Da wir im März ja jetzt wieder auf der Case-Bühne sind, sollten wir uns das
nochmal genauer anschauen, alles.
Ja, ich befürchte auch, es ist halt immer sehr schlimm, sich das anzusehen.
Also ich muss auch hier bei so zwei MyTea-Videos arg leiden.
Denn es gab also… Hast du Beef jetzt gegen MyTea?
Soll ich Beef machen gegen sie? Wir gehen da jetzt mal sehr nüchtern dran.
Rufen uns noch mal kurz aus der letzten Folge in Erinnerung.
Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann sagt, es geht doch keinem schlechter durch den Ukraine-Krieg.
Und keiner Nachteile, weil wir der Ukraine geholfen haben.
Und uns fallen so ein paar Dinge ein, die jetzt wirtschaftlich eher desolat
sind für sehr viele Leute. Aber natürlich nicht, wenn man im Bundestag sitzt,
10.000 Euro hat, erster Klasse, Bahncard und und und.
Aber ja, jetzt ist also myteam mit diesem Statement nach vorne getreten und
das war aber ein Prank. Es war eigentlich nur der Teaser für die...
Neue Staffel ihrer Sendung, die sie macht, diese Wissenschaftssendung und dort
meldet sie sich dann zu Wort und sagt, also Leute, ich gehe nicht in die Politik,
ich wollte nur mal so euch vorführen, wie das so alles funktioniert und populistisches Sprechen.
Nun ist es ja auch gar nicht so weit her, dass sich Einzelpersonen entscheiden,
ich brauche meine eigene Partei, siehe letzte Generation,
die jetzt auch ins Europaparlament wollen und wir hören jetzt mal hier in diese
neue Staffel rein, dort soll uns nämlich jetzt erklärt werden,
wie Populismus funktioniert.
Es werden populistische Narrative überall rauf und runter diskutiert,
ständig wiederholt und schön ins öffentliche Bewusstsein einmassiert.
Es funktioniert leider zu gut.
Aber heute holen wir uns den Diskurs zurück.
Und zwar nach unserem Lieblingsmotto Wissen ist Macht.
Wir werden heute verstehen, was uns nicht nur den demokratischen Diskurs versaut,
sondern im schlimmsten Fall sogar die Demokratie selbst kosten könnte.
Reden wir über Populismus.
Und ich wundere mich so, ich habe das nicht gesehen.
Aber sie steht auf der Bühne, vorher sitzt die Leute, okay.
Ja, Publikum und ein paar Einspieler und zwei Schauspieler.
Das klang immer noch so nach YouTube-Situation irgendwie, statt nach Studio.
Ja, im Prinzip ist es ja auch keine Show. Sie steht da, spricht frontal in die
Kamera, guckt vom Telefon.
Könnte man eigentlich auch am Schreibtisch machen, ne? Bräuchte man gar nicht
80 Leute und Millionen Budget.
Man könnte die Show komplett am Schreibtisch machen, ja. Aber jetzt hat man
nun mal sich gedacht, wir müssen da hier eine große Wissenschaftsshow machen.
Und ich sag mal so, wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2024.
Wir kennen jetzt diese Diskussion, was ist Populismus? Wie funktioniert Populismus?
Gibt es Linken? Gibt es Rechten? Gibt es Guten?
Gibt es Schlechten? Das haben wir jetzt seit 15 Jahren etwa.
Ist das mit dem Aufkommen der AfD? Auf jeden Fall. Wir hatten es vorher schon mit Berlusconi.
Also wir haben das alles schon mal durchdekliniert. Ich würde sagen,
da muss jetzt nicht nicht nochmal Grundlagenarbeit geleistet werden,
sondern man könnte jetzt sagen, ja, wir kennen ja alle diese Erkenntnisse,
wie das so in etwa funktioniert, populistische Rhetorik. Aber was machen wir denn dann?
Aber das wird hier gar nicht geleistet, sondern hier wird das jetzt nochmal so abgearbeitet.
Und damit wären wir bei der nächsten vereinfachten Gruppenidentität,
die da oben. Also wir das Volk gegen die Elite.
Kurz, wir gegen die. Die Elite da oben wird natürlich grundsätzlich als schlecht
dargestellt und völlig egal, wer gerade an der Macht ist, der Mythos ist immer,
die Macht gehe nicht vom Volke aus,
man müsse sie sich, notfalls mit Gewalt, zurückholen.
Nun ja, unser Anliegen ist ja, aufgrund Lektüre Rutger Breschmann,
die da oben etwas genauer auszuflacken und nicht zu sagen, da ist nichts da oben.
Ja. Ja.
Ich glaube, MIT ist hier auf dem Holzweg.
Völlig auf dem Holzweg. Würden wir sagen, wenn Marie-Agnes Strackzimmermann sagt,
es geht doch keinem schlechter durch den Ukraine-Krieg und das deutsche Engagement,
ist das dann nicht, die da oben sagt uns da irgendwas, hat mit den Entscheidungen,
die sie trifft, dann in ihrem Alltag gar nichts zu tun, weil sie das finanziell
nicht betrifft, die anderen betrifft es aber, ist da die, die da oben und wir
Opposition nicht richtig.
Man kann immer sagen, dieses Wir ist eigentlich viel heterogener und Wir meint
ja nicht einheitlich, homogen, völkisch oder so etwas,
sondern kann ja einfach sagen, die Leute, die unter zweieinhalbtausend Nettoimmunen
nach Hause bringen, die merken es besonders stark gerade, was alles teurer geworden ist.
Listen to the science. Ich habe vorhin Lage der Nation gehört,
ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ich habe heute Morgen so viel gehört,
aber irgendwo gab es ein Gespräch, ich glaube es war Lage der Nation,
mit jemandem, der eine Steuerreform vorschlägt, die nicht allzu tief eingreift,
sondern einfach nur sagt, so ein paar Sachen müssten sein, um zu 75 Milliarden
mehr Steueraufkommen zu kommen.
Er schlägt dann eine Erbschaftssteuerreform vor und sagt gleich,
bevor der Widerspruch kommt oder die Frage, hat nicht jeder was zu vererben
und so weiter. Nein, es hat nicht jeder was zu vererben.
Sie zielt auf die 300 ertragreichsten Erben ab pro Jahr.
So 300 von 80 Millionen Menschen werden also von dieser Erbschaftssteuerreform
betroffen. Das kann man gar nicht anders als die da oben klassifizieren.
Wenn man jetzt in Deutschland ein Einkommensniveau hat, bei dem man mit 7.500
Euro netto im Monat zur Top 1% der Einkommensklasse zählt,
sitzen alle im Bundestag in dieser Klasse. Das ist also die da oben.
So, wir könnten das jetzt, also wenn sie so eine Sendung macht,
müsste sie eigentlich das eigentliche Argument, nämlich nicht über die da oben
reden, sondern über die da unten.
Also die Schicksalsgemeinschaft untere Klasse nochmal formen.
Und so wie wir es ja auch immer wieder betonen oder ich immer sage,
Deutschland ist viel größer, als man immer glaubt.
Es gibt so unendlich viele Menschen, die einfach sich so durch ihr Leben schleppen
und gar nicht richtig vorwärts kommen. Und wenn man das thematisiert,
muss man gar nicht über die da oben sprechen, sondern das Gefühl kommt trotzdem auf.
Es gibt so Leute, die da oben irgendwie mit entsprechendem Top-1-Prozent-Einkommen
plus Bankart 100, die es einfach mal noch so oben drauf gibt,
weil kann man ja selber darüber entscheiden,
also macht man das so, würde jeder andere auch, wenn er selber darüber befinden
könnte, sich eine Bankart 100 geben, aber die machen es halt einfach.
Also die da oben ist, sagen wir mal populistisch, etwas missbraucht als Begriff,
aber trotzdem einer der wichtigsten politischen Grundbegriffe überhaupt. Die da oben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum man da so dagegen sein kann. Das ist doch,
listen to the science sagt, die da oben ist mit einer der wichtigsten Grundbegriffe,
um die Demokratie zu retten.
Und ich meine, sollen normale Arbeitnehmer sich mit Christian Lindner identifizieren?
Sollen die mit dem ein Wir bilden? Sollen die sagen, wir, Christian Lindner und ich sind dafür das?
Nein. Da muss man fragen, ob noch alles richtig ist im Oberstübchen.
Scott Galloway hat gestern ein Threat-Post gemacht, also auf dieser Meta-Plattform.
Hat einfach nur geschrieben, Respekt. Wozu? Er hatte verlinkt einen Text in
der New York Times, in dem behandelt wurde, wie Taylor Swift aufgerufen hat,
sich an den Super Tuesday-Wahlen zu beteiligen. Das stand ja immer in der Rede.
Schlägt sie sich auf irgendeine Seite, macht sie es explizit,
wie auch immer. Und sie hat nur einen Punkt gemacht.
Und da würde ich auch sagen, Respekt. Sie hat gesagt, wählt die,
von denen ihr euch am meisten repräsentiert fühlt, also mit denen ihr solche
Ähnlichkeitsgefühle, wie du sie
jetzt beschrieben hast, soll man sich mit Christian Lindner gemein machen.
Egal aus welcher Richtung es betrachtet, die da oben ist wirklich ganz wichtig.
Das muss nicht nur den Leuten ausgetrieben werden, sondern es muss in sie reingetrieben werden.
Ja, wenn Eva Högl von der SPD sagt, die jungen Leute müssen sich jetzt auch
mal wieder engagieren und deswegen brauchen wir eine Dienstpflicht,
dann muss man darüber nachdenken, wer verfügt dann jetzt gerade über die Zeit
von Millionen junger Menschen?
Die da oben, Eva Högl.
Wir hören mal weiter rein.
Ein wichtiges Werkzeug der Populistinnen und Populisten ist ihre Rhetorik. Wie funktioniert das?
Oft checkt man das gar nicht, obwohl man direkt daneben steht.
Wir haben uns deshalb den Giftschrank der rhetorischen Populismus-Tricks einmal genauer angesehen.
Hier unsere Top 5. Trick Nummer 1.
Die schweigende Mehrheit. Oft geht der Mythos, wie das folgt,
nicht ganz so gut auf, wenn man mit seiner Gruppenidentität in der Minderheit ist.
Der Trick, man redet einfach eine schweigende Mehrheit herbei.
So, MyTea, wir haben gerade nur so einen sachten Witz gemacht,
sitzt also nicht mehr an ihrem Schreibtisch zu Hause mit einer Tasse Tee und
einer Kamera, sondern ein Team von 80 Leuten baut ihr diese Show. Warum?
Damit sie unterhaltsamer ist. sie greift also ganz schön tief in Methodentrickisten
in dem Glauben naja, bei YouTube haben mich 80.000 Leute gesehen,
aber ich hätte gerne 8 Millionen.
Also baue ich mir inhaltlich macht es ja keinen Unterschied. Einfach ein.
Ästhetisches Setting drumherum. So, wie lange haben wir darunter gelitten,
dass die Politikseite des FAZ-Filters oder so, also die Politikseite oder das
Filter, unlesbar waren.
Weil da irgendwelche Professoren so, naja, die Leute kommen ja eh nicht drumherum,
was sollen sie sonst lesen, außer mich?
Ich roste das hier mal einfach so hin. Niemand hat irgendwas verstanden.
So, das ging bis in die 90er.
Dann kam irgendwann das Internet und alle
so, ja, wir müssen ein bisschen unterhaltsamer, aber darf es ruhig sein.
Es darf ruhig ansprechend sein. Es muss nicht das trockenste,
langweiligste überhaupt sein, mal über sein eigenes Leben was zu lesen. So.
Ich saß ja vor zehn Jahren, ich habe es ja häufiger betont, da bei der Bundespressekonferenz
diesen ganzen Deutschlandfunkleuten gegenüber gesagt, schaut euch doch die Influencer
und Trump an und übernehmt die Methoden.
Wenn ihr mit den Inhalten nicht zufrieden seid, nehmt die Methoden.
Denn das ist das, was anschlussfähig ist. Nicht die Inhalte.
Wir haben also, finde ich, die Welt gerade so drauf getrimmt,
nee, als Politiker wäre es schon ganz gut, gute Klamotten anzuziehen.
Wir haben es thematisiert.
Kleinen Sprachkurs zu machen. So ein bisschen rhetorisch sich vorzubilden,
sagen wir mal so allgemein.
Und jetzt kommt sie und sagt, das sind die Red Flags, die euch zeigen,
hier werdet ihr in die Irre geführt.
Ich bin wieder im vollen Veto.
Und ich bin es auch beim nächsten Beispiel. Beispiel.
Machen wir weiter mit Trick Nummer drei, dem Ad hominem Argument.
Ad hominem heißt so viel wie gegen die Person gerichtet und ist auch alles andere als ein Argument.
Statt dem Gegenüber was Sachliches oder Inhaltliches zu entgegnen,
weicht man auf persönlichen Angriff aus. Schauen wir uns auch das in einem Beispiel an.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, es waren dann zwei Schauspieler da,
die immer so Sketche aufgeführt haben.
Wir sehen jetzt hier eine Mutter mit Kinderwagen, die raucht und ein Herr,
der mit einem Hund vorbeigeht und sich genau darüber empört.
Guck, guck, guck, gaga. Ja, Fifi, ja. Ja, geht's dir gut? Ja, musst du kacka?
Kacka. Ja, komm, wir machen gleich Kacka. Äh, hallo, Entschuldigung,
das arme Kind, das wird doch davon krank.
Also von Ihnen als Hundehalter lasse ich mir gar nichts mehr sagen.
Personenangriffe à la Ad hominem hat man vor allem dann nötig,
wenn die sachliche Argumentationsbasis dünn ist.
Jetzt frage ich dich.
Wir wissen alle, was das ist, das Ad hominem Argument, aber ich frage dich,
von welchem Zuschauer geht man eigentlich aus, wenn man glaubt,
man müsse mit solchen Sketchen ihm die Welt erklären?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ist das nicht zynisch?
Es ist viel schlimmer. Ich habe ja schon hier ausgerufen, ich will nie wieder
ein Panoptikum-Argument hören.
So, weg damit.
Ich will auch nie wieder den Hinweis
hören, dass man bitte Kausalität und Dingsdabums nicht verwechselt.
Korrelation.
Korrelation. Kann ich auch nicht mehr hören. Ad hominem, das habe ich gedacht,
hätten wir schon vor zehn Jahren ausge... Also das will auch niemand mehr hören, diesen Hinweis.
Ja.
Schlimm.
Das ist wirklich nicht ganz schlimm. Das ist wirklich ein Wahlkampf,
der nur mit Personen die ganze Zeit funktioniert. Das Fernsehen zeigt uns permanent nur Personen.
Das kommt dann noch dazu. Aber wie viele Jahre hat man denn nicht am Internet
teilgenommen, um sich jetzt nochmal über über ad hominem Argumentationen aufklären zu lassen.
Und ich, keine Sorge, wir gehen jetzt nicht diese ganzen fünf Beispiele durch,
das geht dann noch weiter, wir können uns das aber alles denken,
haben wir alles hundertmal gehört.
Und ich würde einfach mal sagen, ja, ich kenne diesen Populismus der Leute und
ja, wir alle kennen Videos von Aiwanger oder Gauland, wir werden sie jagen oder
wir sind die eigentliche Mehrheit und all das.
Und ja, da würde ich sagen, jeder, der jetzt so ein bisschen 2 und 2 zusammenziehen
kann, der wird da die populistische Rhetorik erkennen, ohne vielleicht den Fachbegriff parat zu haben.
Die Sache ist ja die, dass wir ganz viel populistische Politik betreiben können,
ohne populistische Rhetorik.
Also wenn man sich ansieht, wie zum Beispiel die FDP die Blockade des Lieferkettengesetzes
argumentiert, dann wird man dort so gut wie keinen Populismus finden.
Die meisten sagen, es geht darum, dass wir auch an die kleineren Unternehmer
in Deutschland denken, wir dürfen denen nicht zu viel Verantwortung und Bürokratie
aufbürden, wir brauchen eher einen schlanken Staat.
Und das in dieser stressigen Zeit, wo eh alle schon im Chaos versinken.
Richtig, also das ist überhaupt keine Rhetorik, die man jetzt bei MIT wiederfinden
kann und das ist so das Interessante,
dass wir eigentlich hier so eine Idee haben von, wenn wir die Kommunikation
durchschauen und die Kommunikation verändern,
dann werden wir auch schon die Welt verändern und das ist einfach nicht der
Fall und wir hören jetzt mal rein in dieser Beichte,
ja ich wollte in die Politik, stimmt aber gar nicht.
Aber vor allem euch muss ich jetzt etwas sehr Wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe in meinem Anti-Populismus-Video am Ende selbst Populismus angewendet. Da war alles dabei.
Wir das Volk gegen die da oben. Hallo Berlin, hallo hier unten.
Wir die vernünftige Mehrheit. Wir haben keinen Bock mehr.
Ich als Außenseiterin, die nicht so ist wie die Elite. Manchmal ist es gar nicht
so verkehrt, einen festgefahrenen Betrieb mit einem Außenseiterblick aufzuwirbeln.
Ja, aber da muss ich auch sagen, das stimmt ja auch. Das stimmt aber überall.
Deswegen haben Unternehmen Unternehmensberater, dass von extern jemand reinkommt
und sagt, naja, was machen sie da eigentlich?
Das ist doch viel zu aufwendig. Das ist alles Populismus.
Die es bestimmt auch viel besser machen würde, denn wie sagt man so schön,
wenn du willst, dass es gut wird, musst du es halt selbst machen.
Ja, aber das ist doch das, was die ganze Zeit gesagt wird. Geht doch mal in
die Politik, macht was, verändert was, engagiert euch.
Also Nerds an die Macht, so werden wir von der Politik verarscht.
Also so heißt diese Sendung auf YouTube. Natürlich auch Populismus pur.
Warum haben wir das alles gemacht? Nicht nur für die Aufmerksamkeit,
sondern auch, weil wir zeigen wollten, wie anfällig wir alle für Populismus sind.
Oh ja, und ich habe gerade das SPD-Wahlprogramm gelesen, damit du es nicht tun musst.
Und da würde ich sagen, mit all den rhetorischen Tricks, die MIT hier vorführt,
wird man bei dem Programm nicht weiterkommen.
Da findet sich nichts, würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Da findet sich nichts dergleichen drin. Aber man liest da zum Beispiel ein ganzes
Kapitel zum Thema Migration,
bei dem man den Eindruck gewinnt, die SPD versucht immer auf Seiten der Menschenrechte
zu stehen, immer da migrationsoffen zu sein.
Nein, nur steht das dann halt so da, dass man sagt, ja, wir müssen Flüchtlingen
eine Perspektive geben und zwar eine klare, eindeutige.
Naja, und diese Perspektive kann natürlich dann auch bedeuten,
dass man ihnen sagt, sie werden in Europa keine Perspektive haben,
sie dürfen nämlich hier gar nicht rein, Frontex wird sie abblocken.
Das ist nur alles ganz anders formuliert, kommt völlig ohne populistische Rhetorik
heraus, kommt im Gewand der Vernunft, des Listen to the Science und so weiter
daher, ist aber natürlich auch ganz schlimme Politik. Kritik.
Ich würde jetzt auch noch weitergehen, wenn sie jetzt einfach nur sagt,
Demokratie, das ist eben Kompromiss.
Mir fällt Populismus auch nicht so leicht auf, wenn er Haltungen vertritt,
die meinen entsprechen.
Denn das Gefühl, die da oben vertreten uns nicht richtig, kennen wir wohl alle.
Demokratie ist halt voller Kompromisse und Träge. Da ist Frust normal.
Ja, es ist nur komisch, dass die Kompromisse dann von denen da oben oft so aussehen,
dass die meisten in der Bevölkerung die Lasten zu tragen haben.
Und ich muss das wirklich jetzt einmal sagen, die Bild-Zeitung hatte ja so ZDF-Gehälter
veröffentlicht und ich bin auch gar nicht dagegen, dass Leute da beim öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehen auch viel verdienen.
Das muss irgendwo in einem Verhältnis stehen.
Man weiß aber auch, dass sie natürlich im Privatfernsehen wesentlich mehr verdienen würden.
Aber da war auf dieser Liste, man weiß nicht, ob man ihr Glauben schenken kann,
war zu lesen, dass MyTea pro Jahr vom ZDF 349.000 Euro bekommt.
Also sie gehört zu denen da oben finanziell gesehen. Ja.
Ich finde das jetzt nicht an sich schlimm, dass sie das Geld bekommt,
man kann sehr darüber streiten, ob das sinnvoll ist, ob das nicht auch für alle
weniger sein könnte und es würden sich trotzdem Leute finden lassen, die beim ZDF arbeiten,
ich gehe davon aus, mit viel Geld bekommt man auch nicht unbedingt mehr Qualität,
aber lassen wir es mal so dahingestellt.
Ich finde aber auf jeden Fall, wenn man eine solche Summe verdient,
dann sollte man nicht dastehen und den anderen zurufen,
naja Demokratie, das ist eben Kompromiss, so ist es nun mal,
aber keine Sorge, die repräsentieren euch schon da oben, denn das ist ja unsere tolle Demokratie.
Dann macht man wirklich staatstragendes Fernsehen.
Dann sagt man einfach nur, ich bin dazu da, um euch nochmal zu sagen,
beruhigt euch, ja nicht aufmucken, ist alles in bester Ordnung.
Ach du bist arm, du bist Student und weißt jetzt nicht, wie du die letzte Woche
im Monat, ja also das ist Demokratie auch.
Genau, der Bundestag hat entschieden, du musst dich jetzt damit abfinden.
Du wirst jetzt als Opfer und Unterlegener in der Mehrheitsentscheidung isoliert.
Das war das Punkt.
Ja, wir hören noch den letzten Clip.
Aber sonst habe ich jedes Wort in diesem Video schon so gemeint.
Ich glaube an eine vernünftige Mehrheit im Sinne von, wenn es so etwas gibt
wie eine echte schweigende Mehrheit, dann sind es die ganzen nicht extremen
Menschen, die zu langweilig sind, um Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen.
Umso besser, dass diese Mehrheit, wenn es drauf ankommt, doch nicht schweigt,
sondern zu Hunderttausenden auf die Straßen geht, um unsere Demokratie zu verteidigen.
Also jetzt doch oder was?
Jetzt doch, aber bitte als gleichzeitige Status Quo-Verteidigung.
Also es soll nicht einfach nur eine Demonstration gegen rechts sein,
sondern eigentlich soll jede Demonstration, die da stattfindet,
auch nochmal sagen, uns geht es ja eigentlich super in der besten Demokratie aller Zeiten.
Und das ist ja wirklich ein Problem,
wenn man das so macht, wenn man versucht jetzt diese Anti-AfD-Demonstrationen
gleichzeitig so zu framen, dass das auch das Einverständnis mit allem ist,
was sonst so politisch passiert.
Und weshalb wir ja auch sagen, die Ampelpolitiker sollen da bitte nicht auftreten.
Wir wollen nicht Ministerpräsidenten dort haben.
Die sind in gewisser Weise Teil des Problems.
Dies ist eine Anti-Rechts-Demonstration, die aus den Bürgern herauskommt.
Und die nicht dazu da ist, zugleich den Herrschenden zu sagen,
ihr habt das super gemacht und wir verhindern mit euch gemeinsam die AfD.
Sondern das müssen die Herrschenden auf andere Weise tun. Ja.
Wir haben ja über die Duelling Dystopias gesprochen,
die sich duellierenden Dystopien, die ja sich in Deutschland auch niederschlagen,
also so wie in Amerika, die beiden Wähler glauben, Trump schafft die Demokratie
ab und die Trump-Wähler glauben, die Demokraten schaffen die Demokratie ab.
Also die sind auf Augenhöhe, was den Vorwurf angeht. Sie glauben nicht,
dass man noch innerhalb des demokratischen Gefüges und so weiter. Das ist ja hier auch.
Also man kommt jetzt nicht raus, indem man irgendwie dann doch nochmal die bessere
Seite ausflaggt und nach so einer Sendung, die eh schon schief und krumm ist,
nochmal ein sich wieder einfangen des,
weil irgendwer in der Redaktion vorher sagte, naja, aber was machen wir jetzt
mit den Demonstranten, die auf der Straße sind und sagen, nee, stopp. Achso, ja.
Ja, da kann ich ja am Ende nochmal so eine moralische Note dranhängen oder so.
So eine Protokollnotiz.
Wir haben uns ja Mühe gegeben, den Populismus aufzuarbeiten und zu bekämpfen,
aber passt ja nicht so ganz mit der Realität zusammen. Also hängen wir das nochmal dran.
Das ist ja blöd. Hat sie denn in der Sendung nochmal Triggerpunkte aufgegriffen?
Nein. Steffen Maus Argumentation mit den vier Arenen der Kommunikation,
mit den Problemen der Überlappungen.
Ich denke, das sind doch, also es liegt ja eigentlich da, ernsthaft über dieses
Populismus-Thema zu reden und es darüber aufzulösen.
Ne, hier das ist so Stand 2014. Man redet darüber, dass es eigentlich so eine
gesunde, liberale, ordentliche Mitte gibt und die ist auch nicht populistisch.
Die Mitte kann nie populistisch sein und die Ränder, die sind populistisch und
gegen die kämpfen wir dann nochmal und finden uns dann alle in dieser Mitte,
in dem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner oder sonst etwas ein.
Und ich denke mal, diese neun soziologischen Erkenntnisse werden wir dann 2034
präsentiert bekommen. Dann werden wir mal diese vier Arenen.
Woran wir gescheitert sind.
Ja, und dann werden wir hier sitzen und wahrscheinlich sagen,
wir können es ja nicht mehr hören. Also jetzt nochmal mit den vier Arenen zu
kommen, ist aber auch ein bisschen spät.
Blöd, blöd, blöd. Okay, ja, das ist wirklich sehr blöd, was da am Fernsehen abläuft.
Schlimm. Dann gehen wir hin zur künstlichen Intelligenz. Wir sprechen im Salon
über Mustafa Suleimans Buch The Coming Wave, Künstliche Intelligenz,
Macht und das größte Dilemma des 21.
Jahrhunderts. Darüber werden wir ausführlich diskutieren. Ich habe einen völligen
KI-Schwerpunkt in dem Salon, denn ich habe noch ein KI-Buch gelesen.
Ich möchte gleich spoilern, es ist das bessere KI-Buch. Es ist von Elena Esposito.
Ich finde es ganz herausragend. Es ist sehr kurz und sehr dicht.
Dann habe ich einen Roman gelesen über eine Frau, die in einer Content-Clickbait-Farm
arbeitet und dort Listicles erstellt.
Also ein Gegenwartsroman, der wirklich ganz nah am heute dran ist.
Du meinst so die besten E-Bikes 2024? Ja.
Auf Nummer sieben wärst du nie gekommen. Ja, genau. So etwas, ja.
Und dann habe ich einen Text über TikTok.
Da sagt die Autorin, nee, ihr habt TikTok noch überhaupt nicht verstanden,
denn TikTok ist eigentlich Fernsehen.
Wir werden uns mit dieser These auseinandersetzen.
Oh, das wird eine interessante These. Ja, sehr gut.
Auseinandersetzen. Dann hat das Handelsblatt recherchiert, wer steckt eigentlich
hinter diesen Profilen, die es jetzt bei Instagram gibt, von sehr schönen Frauen,
die aber alle künstlich generiert sind.
Ich folge gestern einer.
Ah.
Ich möchte wissen, was da vor sich geht.
Ah ja.
Ich habe mir eine rausgesucht, der ich jetzt folge.
Vielleicht ist das ja Lexi oder Emily. Wir gucken gleich mal.
Ich bin gespannt, ab wann sie sich bewegen. Noch sind es ja nur Fotos.
Ja, es gibt schon welche, die sich bewegen. kommen wir, kommen wir zu.
Und dann gibt es einen Text, der wurde mir auch von mehreren geschickt und der
ist tatsächlich sehr interessant von einem Jazzmusiker und Essayisten,
der sagt, es ist das Ende der Entertainment-Kultur.
Es ist etwas Neues da, es ist nicht mehr die alte Opposition, es gibt die Kunst.
U und E, du hast dich ja schon mal ins Feuer gestellt.
Diese Trennung gab es oder man kann die aufrechterhalten.
Das Problem ist nur, die beiden, also Also die U und die E, Musik und sonstige
Kunst und Unterhaltung, sitzen
jetzt im selben Boot und werden angegriffen durch die Dopaminkultur.
Und das ist wirklich sehr, sehr herausragend, was er da zusammengetragen hat.
Und damit werden wir uns also auch beschäftigen.
Ich derweil komme auf meine Lieblingsthemen zu sprechen. Zum einen,
okay, noch ein Wort zur KI.
Ich habe ja Alex Carps Buch angekündigt, über wo es auch so ein bisschen Kunstrichtung geht.
Das verschieben wir nur, wir heben es nicht auf. Ich habe es aber heute nicht
dabei, weil ich mir dachte, wenn Wolfgang nur KI mit hat,
Komme ich mal dazwischen mit so ein paar anderen Themen. Wolfgang hat mich jetzt
gerade überrascht mit dem Esposito-Buch, was natürlich für mich,
wenn Wolfgang jetzt sagt, wie ihr es eben alle gehört habt, ist das bessere
Buch, glaube ich sofort.
Trotzdem halte ich das Mustafa Suleiman-Buch für herausragend und absolut wichtig.
Es ist sozusagen mit der linken Hand am Datenfusionsreaktor und mit der rechten
Hand an der Tastatur geschrieben, von jemandem, der sich wirklich auskennt.
So, ich bin sehr gespannt. Das Esposito-Buch ist eins und das,
was ich auf jeden Fall auch nochmal selber lesen werde und der Suleiman,
ich wundere mich ja immer, warum die Leute dann doch nochmal die Bücher lesen,
obwohl wir sie so ausführlich besprechen. So im Sinne von, vertraut ihr uns nicht?
Ja, nein, wir wollen das selber lesen. Also diesmal das Suleiman-Buch auf jeden Schreibtisch legen.
Wenn euer Chef reinkommt und das Suleiman-Buch da sieht, es sieht zwar ein bisschen
albern aus von der Covergestaltung her, also der erste Blick ist so,
hä? Aber der zweite Blick, wow, sowas liest du? Krass.
Also wer sich updaten, upgraden will, wer zeigen will, dass er eigentlich eine
Null mehr verdient im Jahresgehalt, der muss sich dieses Buch auf den Tisch legen.
Das ist schon ein Kriterium. Ich werde dir im Übrigen viel widersprechen.
Okay, wir lesen außerdem, die FAZ hat nachgeschaut, Arbeitsmarkt,
wohin verschwinden eigentlich die jungen Leute?
Wir hatten ja schon die Statistik zum Thema 50.000 bis 100.000 Schulabgänger.
Nun, wir haben auch viele Schulabgänger mit Abschluss, die danach einfach verschwunden
sind. Man sieht sie nirgendwo. Sie melden sich nicht.
Dunkle Materie der Demografie sozusagen. zu sagen. Außerdem,
die Zeit, den Text lese ich nur, weil ihn mir so viele geschickt haben,
die demografische Entwicklung in Deutschland, Deutschland vergreist nicht mehr, wurde da geschrieben.
Ich möchte also nur kurz diesen Hinweis geben, ja, wir hatten 2022 ein absolutes,
Ausnahmejahr an Migration nach Deutschland, da kann man schon mal so einen Text
machen, aber, und das koppel ich dann mit,
einem Text, den ich auch nur im Salon bringe, damit auf die Frage hin,
du hattest doch mal im Podcast, erzähl das, ich einfach sagen kann,
im Salon, das heißt, da ist ist ein Punkt in der Literaturliste,
da kann man das selber einfach anklicken.
Die Washington Post klärt darüber auf, wie hoch mittlerweile in Südkorea die
Bonuse sind für, du gehst zu deinem Chef und sagst, ich kriege ein Kind.
Man kriegt dafür Geld und ich nenne nur kurz die Summe. Es sind No Strings Attached
75.000 Dollar mittlerweile, die Arbeitgeber dafür zahlen.
Das ist mal eine demografische Katastrophe.
Wir sind eigentlich genauso nah dran, aber wir diskutieren in Deutschland noch ein bisschen anders.
Und außerdem unser Körper. Nach so viel KI werden wir uns ganz am Ende nochmal
um unseren Körper kümmern.
Irgendein Spiegel Online Redakteur hat ein Buch geschrieben,
wie er seinen Körper pflegt.
Und dass es da verschiedene Verjüngungsmechanismen gibt und so weiter.
Außerdem, dieses ganze Fitnessgelaber kommt mittlerweile in der Alten Republik an.
Ich finde, da gibt es interessante Drehs, auf die werden wir nochmal genau kommen.
Und wir werden den Live-Salon nochmal ankündigen und zwar den großen Sommer-Live-Salon,
der im August stattfinden wird.
Das ist auch dann die letzte Gelegenheit für alle, die im Salon sind, das zuerst zu kaufen.
Und wir werden dann im weiteren Verlauf im Frühjahr werden wir dann auch bekannt
geben, wo man an die Karten kommt, also auch für die, die nicht im Salon sind.
Aber jetzt gibt es also die guten Plätze, kann man sich jetzt noch sehr gut
dann reservieren. Man kann, aber es gibt eigentlich keine schlechten Plätze.
Du warst ja jetzt auch gerade da, wir hatten einen Auftritt schon Philippe Ohle
und ich in Bornheim dort und dort kann man tatsächlich von überall sehr gut
sowohl die Leute auf der Bühne als auch die Leinwand sehen. Wir sagen noch ganz
schnell, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Also das ist die Unterstützung. Wer uns unterstützen will, kann das nur auf diese Weise tun.
Wer den Podcast unterstützen will, man kann in den Salon kommen und bekommt
dann dort sehr ausführliche Diskussionen zu Neuerscheinungen und interessanten Texten.
Wir sind erreichbar am besten über Steady.
Das heißt, man geht auf die neue 20er Seite, neue20er.de geht dort auf den Button
zum Salon und kommt dann zu den verschiedenen Paketen bei Steady.
Ab 2,50 Euro im Monat geht es los.
Wer schon bei Patreon ist.
Der kann den Salon auch über Patreon hören,
aber wir empfehlen Steady, dort ist auch das gesamte Archiv hochgeladen,
bei Patreon und auch bei Apple fehlt so ein bisschen was vom Anfang,
aber da ist das gesamte Archiv hochgeladen, das heißt man kann sich wahrscheinlich
durch inzwischen ein paar Tage Salon durchhören. Da ist ja viel aufgekommen.
Seit 2020 im Januar machen wir ja diesen Salon.
Und man kann auch, wenn man bei Spotify den Salon hört, sofort von Spotify dann
den Steady Salon buchen. Außerdem sind wir noch bei Apple.
Da ist es ein bisschen teurer, weil Apple ja 30 Prozent immer Gebühr haben möchte.
Insofern muss man dann auch da ein bisschen mehr für die Bequemlichkeit zahlen.
Und jetzt musst du noch ganz kurz erklären, dass man den Salon hören kann, so wie man möchte.
Man muss ja nicht auf der Steady-Seite am Browser den Salon plötzlich hören.
No, soll man auch gar nicht. Man nimmt seinen Podcast-Player seiner Wahl und
abonniert dort einfach den Salon, weil man kriegt ja als Kunde ein RSS-Feed.
Den kann man dann einfach ganz normal buchen, hören.
Da gibt es Kapitelmarken, wo man von Text zu Text springen kann.
Und ich habe jetzt gesehen bei Apple, Apple hat jetzt dieses Update gemacht,
bei dem sie so EU-konform werden mit diesen ganzen neuen Markets, Acts und so weiter.
Und die Podcast-App von Apple hat jetzt Transkriptionen automatisch drin.
Also die transkribieren selbst und man kann so richtig schön mitscrollen und
es war mal wieder so ein klassisches Apple-Produkt, denn man kriegt gleich so
ein richtig fertiges Ding.
Also man, wenn man das so mitliest, ich habe es heute Morgen bei ein paar Podcasts
versucht, es wird tatsächlich der Satzbau, der ja mündlich durchaus mal ein
bisschen holperig sein kann, einfach gerade gezogen.
Wirklich?
Ja, also so ein richtig schönes Leseerlebnis, plus der Text läuft Läuft wirklich mit.
Also man sieht gerade durch Hinterlegung der Textfarbe, wo man ist.
Man kann dann weiter scrollen, anklicken. Also man kann wirklich gezielt Sachen
überspringen und so weiter.
Es ist wirklich eine Bereicherung für die Podcast-Welt. Ich bin mal gespannt,
inwieweit andere Podcast-Apps danach ziehen können.
Denn da ist schon so ein bisschen Computer-Power vonnöten. Unser letzter 5-Stunden-Podcast
ist zum Beispiel noch nicht transkribiert.
Aber alle anderen Sachen, die, keine Ahnung, es ist jetzt an der Länge lag oder
so, Aber die anderen Sachen sind soweit drin.
Das heißt, die KI kann sich freuen. Sie kann sehr viel Neues jetzt auswerten
und einspeisen in das System.
Es ist direkt eine Suchfunktion unten. Du kannst in dem Podcast suchen und springst
direkt dahin. Also es ist wirklich, schlüsselt das Ganze nochmal ein bisschen auf.
Gut, dann kommt es in den Salon. Es lohnt sich doppelt im März,
weil wir ja noch den Live-Salon machen, der dann auch einen Tag später veröffentlicht wird.
Ungewöhnlicherweise lese ich jetzt ein kurzes Stück aus dem Buch. Suleiman.
Denn wenn wir jetzt gesagt haben, es ist heute ein KI-Schwerpunkt und so weiter,
ich denke mir manchmal...
Bei manchen Themen, die so grundlegend sind, viel verändert sich und vielen
droht auch oder sie spüren, sich so bedroht irgendwie.
Dann kann man ja mal hier einfach sagen, ja, wir haben einen Typ,
der kennt sich mit KI aus, weil er sich selbst entwickelt.
Er hat ja sein Unternehmen damals an Google verkauft und so weiter und so fort.
Wir kommen darauf zu sprechen. Aber es ist eben nicht einfach nur ein KI-Buch,
sondern es ist unter den vielen KI-Büchern, Esposito mal ausgeklammert,
eins, das sich insbesondere auch um die Gesellschaft kümmert,
in der das alles stattfindet.
Also ungefähr auf Seite 250 steht beispielhaft ein Text.
Er ist ein klein wenig länger, als wenn man typischerweise in einem Podcast was vorliest.
Aber ich denke mir, wir lesen es trotzdem mal vor. Wo immer heute Macht vorhanden
ist, wird sie verstärkt werden.
Jeder, der Ziele hat, also jeder, wird bei der Verwirklichung und dieser Ziele
enorme Unterstützung erhalten.
Die Überarbeitung einer Unternehmensstrategie, die Organisation sozialer Veranstaltungen
für eine lokale Gemeinschaft oder die Eroberung feindlicher Gebiete.
All das wird einfacher. Der Aufbau einer Fluggesellschaft oder das Festsetzen
einer Flotte sind ebenfalls leichter zu verwirklichen.
Ob kommerziell oder religiös, kulturell oder militärisch, demokratisch oder
autoritär, jeder nur denkbare Motivation lässt sich durch die Verfügbarkeit
billigerer Mittel drastisch verstärken.
Heutzutage kann man, egal wie reich man ist, schlicht kein leistungsfähiges
Smartphone kaufen, als das, das Milliarden von Menschen zur Verfügung steht.
Diese phänomenale Errungenschaft der Zivilisation wird allzu oft übersehen.
Im nächsten Jahrzehnt wird der Zugang zu ACI, wir kommen darauf zu sprechen,
was er damit meint, demselben Trend folgen.
Dieselben Milliarden Menschen werden bald weitgehend gleichen Zugang zu den
besten Anwälten, Ärzten, Strategen, Designern, Coaches, Assistenten,
Verhandlungsführern haben und so weiter.
Jeder wird ein Weltklasse-Team an seiner Seite und in seiner Ecke haben.
Finde ich eine wahnsinnig gute Formulierung irgendwie, du wirst sie in deiner Ecke haben.
Weil, wer hat jemanden in seiner Ecke? Naja, der Typ, der gerade grün und blau geschlagen wird.
Das wird die größte und rasanteste Beschleunigung des Wohlstands und der Prosperität
in der Geschichte der Menschheit sein. Sie wird aber auch eine der chaotischsten sein.
Wenn jede und jeder Zugang zu mehr Fähigkeiten hat, dann gilt das natürlich
auch für diejenigen, die Schaden anrichten wollen.
Da sich die Technologie schneller weiterentwickelt als die Verteidigungsmaßnahmen,
erhalten böswillige Akteure von mexikanischen Drogenkartellen bis zu nordkoreanischen
Hackern eine Motivationsspritze.
Die Demokratisierung des Zugangs bedeutet zwangsläufig eine Demokratisierung des Risikos.
Wir sind gerade dabei, eine kritische Schwelle in der Geschichte unserer Spezies zu überschreiten.
Damit wird sich der Nationalstaat im nächsten Jahrzehnt auseinandersetzen müssen.
Wir haben es also mit einer politischen Aufforderung zu tun.
Also hier, my team-mäßig, wir sollen uns alle mal ein bisschen mehr und so weiter
Demokratie schützen. Der Nationalstaat spielt eine wichtige Rolle.
Aber dieses Waffengleichheitsargument, ich habe eigentlich immer nach einem
Text gesucht, in dem das mal thematisiert wird.
Ein mittelloser Student, der sich eigentlich gar nichts zutraut und auch weiß,
er steht am Anfang von allem, kann sich trotzdem ein iPhone leisten.
GPT kostet 20 Euro im Monat.
Milliarden Menschen waffengleich. Und hier steht das mal so,
einfach so nebenbei, einfach in so einem Text drin.
Also seid gespannt, ich habe zehn weitere Seiten Anmerkungen,
die ich gleich abfeuere Ich.
Habe acht Seiten.
Und Wolfgang wird dagegen halten und wir sagen, es ist alles nicht so schlimm
Aber ich glaube, das Jahrzehnt, das vor uns steht wird chaotisch Mensch.
Du bist ja richtig apokalyptisch drauf Also wir sehen uns im Salon Yes, bis gleich.